la russie qui s'affiche jusque devant le
symbole de la destruction de marioupol
le théâtre bombardé de la ville les
russes veulent donner l'image d'une
ville où la vie reprend et c'est vrai
que plusieurs écoles ont rouvert un
soulagement pour ces élèves qui ont
passé plusieurs semaines dans des caves
sous les bombardements
j'ai dit maman je veux y aller je le
veux vraiment maintenant dans nos têtes
on est de nouveau capable de s'imaginer
construire un avenir
des cours non plus en ukrainien mais
désormais
en russe
pour trouver du pain de l'eau ou encore
un peu d'électricité
des habitants se rassemblent ici dans le
centre ville alors un écran géant a été
installé il diffuse les chaînes russes
qui diabolise l'ukraine
il raconte comment la russie progresse
et couvents l'ukraine renie ses soldats
mais ce que ne montre pas la télévision
russe
c'est l'autre visage de marioupol
dans ce cimetière en bordure de la ville
aligné à perte de vue
des tombes creusées à la hâte avec un
simple numéro ils vont jusqu'à plus de
des sites comme celui ci il y en a
plusieurs cette femme a voulu nous
montrer où a été enterré son mari il
avait 32 ans il a été tué par un obus il
est dans cette fosse commune
ils soient allongés sur lui niveau les
uns sur les autres sur 8 et par trois en
largeur
désormais valeria se bat pour faire
exhumé et enterré dignement son mari les
gens ont juste été jetés la rivale pas
de cérémonie religieuse à l'église rien
on voudrait l'enterrer de façon humaine
combien de personnes sont mortes à
marioupol dans cette morgue improvisée
pas question de nous répondre
mais des dizaines de corps alignés à
même le sol en plein soleil
car dans la ville les travaux de
déblaiement ont commencé par tous des
civils ensevelies sous les décombres de
leur immeuble depuis plusieurs semaines
ici cinq corps sont sortis il y en
aurait encore trois
je vis depuis 30 ans ici je les
connaissais tous
c'était tous des amis des connaissances
des enfants
des enfants des petits enfants
et en un instant
un terrible tribus qui vient s'ajouter
aux six habitants dont deux enfants déjà
inhumé derrière l'immeuble des tombes de
fortune comme celle ci il y en a des
centaines à marioupol
leur recensement n'a pas encore commencé